from medieval europe onwards the hand of  glory referred to the hand of a hanged  man that was used as a candle-like  trinket with supposed magical properties  the process of making one consists of  cutting the right hand of a dead felon  whilst they were still hanging the hand  would then be pickled in salt and the  urine of a man woman dog or horse  so i guess they weren't too picky it  would then be smoked with herbs and hay  for 30 days until lovely and golden  brown and then hung on an oak tree for  three nights it's believed that the hand  of glory was able to petrify individuals  rendering them motionless and thus it  became a staple for witches and warlocks  it was also thought to be able to unlock  any door it came across a perfect tool  for a thief unless you were caught in  that case it's likely your hand would be  making the next person's hand of glory  and so the rather strange and infinite  cycle continued